[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dane is
in Denver hi Dane welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey welcome to me uh I just I've
always wanted to say this how are you
doing Mr Ramsey better than I deserve
what's up
man hey uh yes I have a really quick
question hopefully um I'm looking to
make a lateral move in housing from one
house to another I currently own my home
that I live in and I'm looking to make a
um flight move not not too far away and
um I see it as two different options
that I have I'm trying to avoid
getting another mortgage out I'm trying
to avoid moving into a rental
temporarily and I'm trying to avoid
storing all my stuff I like to just go
from one house to the other um I see it
as I can do a sale on
contingency or what about these
we buy your house uh services are they a
scam or not well they're not a scam but
they're buying the home to resell it at
a profit which means they have to buy it
from you at Below
Retail right
um yeah the money that I would lose on
that would probably pay for the rental
for how do you know you know I I've done
a little bit of research I know renting
is extremely high here
um and I do work with a lot of
appraisers um in the line of work that I
do I'm a land surveyor I mean all of
this is all of this is assuming that you
think you know what they're going to
offer
you correct correct um I've actually
reached out uh just you know you can
fill out those forms email kind of forms
and um none of them have responded with
a number which kind of shocking makes me
a little weary yeah exactly cuz they
don't want to scare you to death they
want you to sell them the house but dude
I mean it's usually 80 cents on the
dollar. cents on the
dollar oh wow and so it's not it's not a
small it's not like a $2,000 discount or
something I mean it's a lot you're not
desperate are
you no I have time on don't do it don't
just don't do it here's what you need to
do you just need to be patient and do a
contingency
sale okay that's it's I like that yeah
I'm not going to do it otherwise okay I
sold my personal residence when
everything peaked out um two years ago
because it was a real killer opportunity
to get out of that house and um but we
sold it and delayed possession by 4
months okay okay and that gave us four
months to get the other house purchased
and moved into um and but that you know
well uh did you take I I didn't take a
discount I just refused to sell it
otherwise so you're going to refuse to
sell your home out from under
you you're going to sell it on some kind
of terms that allow you to make a one
move all right and then the person I'm
buying it from they also have to agree
to this too correct I mean but what I
would do is start shopping the area that
you think you want to be in and say I
could live there there or there and if
you want to make an offer on one of them
contingent upon the sale of yours fine
typically what most markets do there's
differences in different markets it's
generally culturally uh except the real
estate Community for some reason decides
it in just culturally in a market but
most of the time you'll have like a
72-hour first ride of refusal so if the
seller of the other property that you
wanted to buy accepted a contingency
offer from you it would be contingent
upon the sale of yours and they keep
theirs on the market if they get another
buyer you have 72 hours to say I'll buy
it anyway
and you wouldn't do that you would let
them
go right yeah okay yeah I you're right I
I do have time on my side I'm in no rush
and so if until the right deal comes
together and the right timing for you to
buy the home that you want and move one
time with the sale of yours on a
contingency sale you just don't do it
well they won't they won't take a
contingency contract okay can't buy that
house yeah yep all right I like this
idea and I can just uh just take my time
it's all out of convenience kids got a
new school down the street and yeah and
just what you do is just you know I'm
going to carefully line The Dominoes up
so that when I push them they all fall
and make that beautiful
design my wife and I can do that we've
uh yeah we're totally debt free we um
own our house I'm 42 years old you know
I'm I'm I'm sitting
pretty and the trick is to not get
married to the purchase
house yeah yep there's only one if I
don't get that one the whole no there's
lots of houses you can purchase right so
if you don't get married to a certain
house then you say I I want to move over
there and I like this kind of a property
and whichever one God arranges for this
whole domino system to fall I'll land in
that and I'm going to be happy as a clam
now the second thing you got to Born
yourself against and I have to warn
myself against this too and I'm in the
I've known done real estate my whole
life is when you've got everything lined
up and then someone comes to buy your
house you're you see you're emotionally
motivated to get that deal done so we
can push the dominoes and if you're not
careful you'll discount your home in the
negotiation process because you get all
excited right and just be aware of that
that's human nature yeah I got all this
lined up and you know I don't really
want to take that late little amount but
I'm I want to push the D doino and yeah
now you're about to take $10,000 too L
less too less than you should have so
just just play hard to get and don't get
married to the next one and you can line
these up and you're going to be just
fine and folks I want you to know that
Dave Dave practices what he preaches in
a lot of areas but you did that on that
house and I got to tell you we're
thinking about you're talking about the
house and I got to tell you I'm missing
that porch I don't know how you got rid
of that house with the porch that you
had highest point in Williamson County
yeah I could see 18 miles off of it and
I I just you took me back there for a
second it was beautiful I'm being
selfish it was beautiful I I kind of
missed the Hangouts out there the the
nice people that bought it from us they
paid me for that view yes they did and
that is the moral of the story folks I
mean I I thought you were a little crazy
but it was a good move it was a good it
was a little crazy but it was if you're
ever going to sell a particularly unique
property during a super the hottest time
I've ever known in 35 years of real
estate would be the time do it and you
did and I did it right at the top of
that market so it just you know these
fall evenings and I you know I'm yelling
at somebody all the time on here it's
just a house and then yeah but those
that that house the views on that
property were take it from astronomical
astronomical yeah I do miss that
although I'm I'm nestled down in the
woods now where I've got no view which
is amazing too you like that very quiet
I'm back in Walden Pond here you know so